lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
practicar la suma de decimales aquí dice
12.93 + 6.1 es aproximadamente igual a
este signo de igual ondulado significa
aproximadamente igual a pausa en el
vídeo traten de estimar el resultado y
encontrar la opción correcta resolvamos
estos juntos podemos resolver esto
usando lápiz y papel pero el objetivo
del vídeo es practicar como estimar el
resultado mentalmente y llegar a un
resultado aproximado si quiero estimar
esto en mi mente lo que hago es
redondear el 12.93 a 13 pues es el
entero más cercano 6.1 es un poco mayor
que 6 así que lo redondeo a 6 en este
caso redondear es bueno porque el 6.1 lo
redondea hacia abajo y el 12.93 lo re
donde hacia arriba de donde él 12.93
hacia arriba para llegar al 13 y
redondea el 6.1 hacia abajo para llegar
al 6 así que cuando lo sume tendré un
estimado muy cercano a la respuesta real
13 + 6 es igual
y 9 y vemos que una de las opciones es
en efecto 19 hay muchas formas en las
que podemos hacer esta estimación por
ejemplo una estimación un poco más
precisa sería decir que 12.93 es cercano
a 12.9 y a estos sumarle 6.19 décimas
más una décima es un entero 12 6 es 18
más un entero es 19 encontramos la misma
opción hagamos otro ejemplo 5.1 4.91 es
aproximadamente igual a pausa en el
vídeo y traten de estimar el resultado
aproximado mentalmente yo lo resolvería
de forma similar a como lo hicimos en el
ejemplo anterior el 5.1 lo redondeo a 5
y 4.91 es muy cercano a 5 sumamos cinco
más cinco y nos queda 10 que es la
opción b nuevamente coincidió que este
número lo redondeamos hacia abajo y este
otro número lo redondeamos hacia arriba
así que el resultado de nuestra
estimación será bastante cercano al
resultado real si hubiéramos redondeado
ambos números hacia abajo
y ambos números hacia arriba nuestro
estimado no sería tan parecido al
resultado real así que tendríamos que
ser un poco más cuidadosos veamos el
tercer ejemplo de nuevo pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolverlo por su
cuenta
mentalmente vamos a estimar lo como lo
hemos hecho en los ejemplos anteriores
3.14 es cercano a 3 lo redondeo hacia
abajo para tener el 3 y el 5 punto 92 lo
redondeo hacia arriba para tener un 6
esto coincide con los redondeos de los
ejemplos anteriores ya que el 3.14 lo
redondea hacia abajo quite 14 centésimas
y el 5.92 lo redondea hacia arriba le
agregue 8 centésimas por lo que nuestra
aproximación será bastante cercana a la
respuesta real 36 es igual a 9 que es
nuestra opción c esto es interesante
porque no siempre tendremos varias
opciones de donde elegir la respuesta
pero en este caso si sumamos las
unidades 3 + 5 es igual a 8 por lo que
podemos descartar la primera opción y a
este 8 le vamos a sumar 14
y más 92 centésimas lo que nos da más de
una unidad por lo que podemos ver que la
respuesta será un poco mayor que 9 por
lo que confirmamos que esta es la opción
correcta con esto terminamos